after the assault on the capital social
media companies disabled president
trump's accounts
mr trump was suspended from facebook and
instagram
until the end of his term and
potentially forever
twitter temporarily froze his account
and the president you recall incited the
riot by spewing countless lies about the
election and voter fraud and his tens of
millions of followers
well they include members of the
conspiracy group q anon
so we're going to bring in now 60 in
sixth correspondent and founder of
dot dot dot media lori siegel she got
rare access
to q and on last summer take a look
trump's going to get re-elected what if
he's not re-elected well he's going to
be a re-election what if he's not
realized if president trump is not
re-elected
then that's for the american people to
decide if the elections were fair
i think there's going to be a lot of
very angry americans that he wasn't
reelected
and lori siegel joins us now lori good
morning to you i think people need to
understand that these social media
companies are not like the town square
they're more like a digital bar
you can be thrown out of them and the
president has been how big of a deal is
that
i think it's a huge deal in the time
i've been covering tech everybody's been
asking
the founders of these companies of
twitter or facebook you know
under what circumstances would you ban
president trump and
now i think we finally hit a a breaking
point you know this is
uh if you look at the first amendment uh
you know you can't yell
fire in a crowded theater and all these
tech companies when we've reached out
multiple times saying
you know is this a violation is this a
violation this is misinformation
what they'll say and what facebook has
taken an incredibly hands-off approach
and i think
you know what they'll say is the public
has a right to see
uh see some of these figures but if
there's language that incites violence
they will remove it and i think this was
that breaking news so then here's the
question some of the
the president's allies have been
criticized for not calling out his
behavior earlier and foreseeing the
tragedy we saw
this week do the social media companies
also deserve some criticism for
not getting on top of this dangerous
situation much earlier
yeah i mean for a lot of folks it's it's
too little too late
this has been a conversation i go back i
remember interviewing mark zuckerberg
years ago and saying how does it feel to
be editor-in-chief i mean this shows the
power
of technology and shaping media and
culture
in the conversation but you know people
even internal facebook employees have
been calling for this to happen
for a very long time there have been
multiple examples
of this uh twitter's early investor
chris sacca
tweeted yesterday um both facebook and
uh and twitter have blood on their hands
for rationalizing terror over the last
four years so
i do think it's really interesting you
have to look at the timing
you know you look at the timing of
president trump will be out of office
in two weeks you have a new
administration coming in and you have
facebook
and twitter and these big tech companies
under scrutiny so
you know they're from a new
administration so i think that the
timing is also
pretty noteworthy as well gloria as
you've reported uh so many of these
extremist
groups essentially live and breathe on
social media
what if anything do we know about uh the
role social media played
in in the attacks on the capitol
you know i think this is a this has been
coming uh for a long time i remember
interviewing someone years ago who said
our world is becoming a chat room
and we're becoming our own avatars i
think we're seeing the rise
also of these niche media platforms
where people can live out their own
truth because
facebook banned q anon back in october
but
this is a conspiracy group that was
allowed to
to gather and spread misinformation for
a very long time
millions of people have been looking at
this information
the pandemic only made it worse people
were home without jobs
they were seeking some sense of
belonging uh and it took
these companies a long time and it's
still taking these companies a long time
to get control of this i'll tell you one
noteworthy thing that i heard i spoke to
a source who's close to the q anon
movement who was at the capitol and
and i said what's happening to the q
anon movement um and he said you know
now that it's been banned people are
going to private forums like parlor and
gab to gather and to organize
but he said people are also joining uh
militias
and and beginning to you know try to
seek a sense of belonging offline so i
think we're seeing a new
era of now you know i think it's they've
they've gotten
they're trying to get control of it but
we will this isn't going to go away this
is going to manifest itself in a
different way
lori siegel thank you very much for
being with us this morning